welcome Palace says Lady Susan Hussey
has met charity Boys in gozie Fulani and
apologize for racist comments made as a
palace reception last month well let's
go live now to The Newsroom and to our
Royal correspondents Laura bundock Laura
how did the meeting go what was said
we know that the meeting took place a
little earlier on today the pair met and
we are told that the meeting was filled
with warmth and understanding during the
meeting we're told Lady Susan offered
her sincere apologies for the comments
that she'd made and the distress that
they had caused to miss fellani you may
remember it was at a reception last
month at Buckingham Palace when Lady
Susan Hussey who was very very close to
the queen had been one of her ladies and
waiting for many many years repeatedly
asked where are you from where are you
from and it was those comments that
caused her to have to step down from
this honorary role it sparked the palace
to have to respond quickly to
allegations of institutional racism
anyway the pairs I say have met today we
also understand that Miss falani has
accepted the apology and appreciates
that No Malice was intended and here's a
note also from Buckingham Palace that
the Royal households they say are going
to continue their focus on inclusion and
diversity with an enhanced program of
work which will extend knowledge and
training programs examining what can be
learned from the sister space which is
one of the organizations that we know
degosi Fulani works very closely with we
also understand the king and queen
consort have been kept informed and are
said to be pleased that the parties have
reached what they describe as a welcome
outcome so news today just in the
earlier on today Lady Susan Hussey met
and apologized to nagosi Fulani after
those racist remarks were made at
Buckingham Palace last month